おっ
[拍手]
こんにちは
影響はこのできない
不幸の連鎖を断ち切るたった一つの方法について話をさせていただきます
その方法等は実はペニスから学びました
テニスから学んだやり方で国語を指導すると不幸の連鎖を断ち切ることができるそう
いうことをお伝えできたらと思っております
今日はよろしくお願いします
[拍手]
私はテニスの上級指導員の資格習得のために東京にあるナショナルオリンピック
センターというところで研修を受けました
そのときにこの子演技単位について順番について学んだんですね
みなさんでしたらこの心技体
どの順番から教えられますか
ちょっとメモ用紙があると思うので一番は
何一番は何一番は何という形でちょっと書いていただけますか
ありがとうございますちょっと隣近所見てもらえますか
はい心を一番に持ってきた人のぐらいいらっしゃいますか
客観いますねその人はですね
気合と根性が大好きで頑張れとかやる気を出せというフレーズをよく言う人ですね
で次体を一番に持ってきた人はどのくらいいらっしゃいますか
あー体の方が多いですねこの人はですねええ
とにかく練習時間を確保する
で相手を追い詰める
で膨大な練習をすることが大好きな人ですね
例えば勉強で言うと料やるっていう
学習量を増やすことがいいんだっていう考えるような指導方法です
じゃ最後に
技を持ってきた人はどのくらいやいらっしゃいますか
さすがですねー
技を一番に持ってきた人はですねスキルに注目をして出来ることを増やし
自信をつけていくことが始動だと考えています
小手先のテクニックではなくてできたという喜びをモチベーションにして指導するのが
技という指導方法です
大切なのはですね
どれかが実か正解ではないんです
ジダンや状況条件によって変わってくることは確かなんです
ただ
心と体の指導を中心にして指導すると時間がかかり
過剰な努力を貸して
結果的に効率が悪くなってしまいます
そうしてやってもやっても先が見えないという精神的な苦痛を感じる人が今の時代
とても多いんですね
心や体の指導を代表する気合と根性
これ自身私が決して誤りだとは思っていません
現実この指導によってのみた政党がたくさんいることは確かです
ターン
今回この技による指導によって
もあるのだという事を皆さんに知っていただきたいと考えています
例えば心と体で3分の2の生徒が延びていいだとしましょう
残りの3分の1の生徒の可能性が開くと思って頂ければ嬉しいなと考えています
私はこの心と体の指導っていうのを
短所改善方指導という風に呼んでいます
この短所改善方指導というのはどんな指導かというと
を例えば
マルとバツがありますよね人間には長所と短所があると思ってください
そのマルとバツを罰の部分を
気合と根性で消していくことが短所改善方指導というふうに私は読んでいます
このやり方自体で大事なのは動機付けがしっかりとしていればいいです
ただしっかりとしていない場合には
できないところに無理やり働きかけるためによしやってやるぞという精神的なストレス
が
前向きな気持ちっていうのになかなかなりにくいというところがこの問題点です
それとは対極の指導方法にこの調書活用形指導というのがあります
先ほどの
マルとバツの例で言うと
まるつまりできることを増やすことで結果的に罰に注目がいかないようにするっていう
やり方だと考えてください
例えば私の教室に国語が苦手だっていう風にして精度が通ってきます
心の指導度をメインにすると例えば話し合ったりとかやる気を出そうねーとか
時には叱咤激励したりとかいう風な形で心のメンタルの部分に働きかけて伸ばそうとし
ます
体の始動だとどうするかって言ったらやはりもう
問題量
とにかく学習時間を取らせようっていう指導になってきますでは
技術の指導っていうのはどういう風にするか
って言ったら私は基本的なスキルたとえば文字を読むというそのもののスピードに注目
をします
そもそも国語の問題が読めていないというのではなくても子を処理するスピードが遅い
ために読むことそのものに使えてしまって結果的に国語ができないなってなってるだけ
なんじゃないかっていう風に考えます
試しに計算テストをしてみるんですね
すると
だいたい国語ができない子は単純な計算処理が遅いです
例えば1分の目標のところが場合によっては3分かかります
で次にたとえば文字の処理
有名なのが音読とか暗唱なんかをさせてみるんですね
するとこれもかなり弱いです
ということは国語ができないと思い込んでいる生徒の多くは基本的な読み書き計算の
処理が弱いっていうことがわかってきました
これでは例えば10分の問題だと水ます
すると処理が弱いがために30分以上かかります
読むことそのものに疲れます読むことそのものに疲れると当然制限時間があるので問題
が解けません
問題が解けないから当然結果悪いですよね
で悪くなった結果をまた自分自身が見て落ち込みますよね
で落ち込んであぁ私行って勉強というの向いてないんだって言って勉強が嫌いになって
いくんですよ
こういう悪循環を生まないようにするために
技による指導というのは大事ななって考えているんですね
そもそもこんな考え方で
この生徒っていうのは能力がないんですかね
それともやり方が間違っているんですかね
私はこのできないと思っている生徒というのはほとんどが
能力や才能によるものではないという風に考えています
むしろ基本的な文字を読むというスキルそのものが弱いために
結果として表面的に勉強ができないという状態になっているだけなんじゃないかなって
いうふうに考えています
そこでその後が持っているスキルつまり長所を活用しながらな
伸ばしてやることでまずは勉強ができる状態にしてしまおうという考え方です
それではですねお待たせしました皆さんの長所についてちょっと今日は確認したいと
思いますので
メモ用紙を準備してもらえますか
よろしいですか私が今から10桁の数字を言いますので
それを書き留めるだけです
準備はできましたかちょっと練習1回してみます
いきます
に9467
はいでは隣近所と答え合わせをしてみてください
よろしいですか
ちょっと気合を入れていきますよ
はいで本番いきます
33497645に5
配送やボタンを押せ押してください
ok ですが
はい全問正解の人入っ
はいすばらしいですはいそれではだんだんプレッシャーをかけていきます私が今から
いう数字に+1を足して書いてください
私がさんって言ったら皆さん何て書きますか
4賢いですいきますよ
76に15
4入っ答え合わせしてください
大丈夫
どうですか
さあさらにもう1回ラストになりますここでプレッシャーをかけていきますね
私が今からいう数字に-1
押してください
私が読んでいたら皆さんは
三愛賢いですねいけますよ
15に634
背後丹精してください
はいどうでしたか全問正解の人入っ
この人はですね長所として耳です
耳です耳の処理が得意ですあー今回苦手だったなーっていういう人は何かって言ったら
第二代目の処理です
これが長所だと思ってくださいですのでどちらがどちらの処理が得意なのかを聞いた
だけであって
それに優劣があるわけではないです
このように情報処理するっていう単純な作業でも2種類あるっていうことを今日は知っ
てください
例えば
全体として目の処理だけの人が多いとしましょう
こういう人に向かって私がしゃべるだけの始動だとどうですか
とても苦手の処理になってきますしたがってうまくできません
でも生徒って結構頑張るんです非常に真面目に取り組んでくれますただ不得意な処理な
だけにうまくいかないですよね
頑張っても頑張っても認めてもらえない
頑張っても頑張っても本当に褒めてもないなぁ褒めてもらいたいあえてから否定されて
しまう
だからやってもで自分はどうせ出来ないんだ
落ち込むことになってきます
さらに自分で自分を否定していくことになってきます
私には才能がないんですって最後にはそういう風になってきます
こういうのって
不幸の姉さだと思いませんか
この不幸の連鎖を断ち切るために私は
技による指導が第一だという風に考えています
そんな私ですけども実はあるときまで気合と根性でしかし道ができませんでした
その指導方法が変わったのはとあるテニスコーチに出会ってからです
私はこの生徒は全然うまくありませんからっていう風に言っていた生徒に対して
そのコーチが指導するとなんと一瞬でボールの音が変わったんです
そのコーチは何て言ったか
身体全体の中で腕の筋力っていうのはたった6%しかないからもっと大きい肉を使って
売ったらこんなボール誰でも打てるよって言うんです
そんな事をサラっと言われて指導って自分の経験に基づいたりとか
精神論って大事だと思っていた私には正直衝撃的でした
このやり方が私自身の人生を大きく変えていきました
でその後生徒はどうなったか
もっとうまくなりたい
もっともっと練習したい
本当に楽しそうに練習するんです
練習って苦しいもの勉強ってしんどいものっていうふうに思っていたと彼あたしにとっ
てこの事が大きく人生を変えるきっかけでした
そしてこの指導方法をなんとか
国語に応用できないかなって考えて今の指導にたどり着きました
実はですね教室に通ってくる生徒の90%以上が
女の処理が得意なんです
ということは私がこうやって丁寧に説明して論理的に話をしても実は誰も伝わってない
んです
むしろ全く聞いてないです
大可賀例えばパーパーを使った井戸がプロジェクターを使ったりとか
話のまず全体概要を伝えたりとか図式化することによって伝わるようになるんです
つまりは精度が持っている得意に注目をして指導すると国語苦手だと思っていた国語が
実はなんだ簡単じゃんっていう風に言ってくれるようになってきました
実は国語だけじゃないんですね
例えば
苦手だなぁとかできないなぁと思うこともやり方を変えれば意外にガラッと変わるこ
とってあるんです
よくありませんかお子さん
宿題をしない時
なんでやらないのって
血圧を上げるよりは
今夜の予定をちょっと教えてよっていう風に言って実際紙に書いてそれをお互い見える
形にしてみてください
例えば部下の人が俺の指示を守らないっていう人がいたとしましょう
その人に今言った事をもう面けどメールで返してって言えば実は伝わってないことが
確認できます
あれこれ考えてなんか上手くいかないなぁっていう時もあると思います
そういう時には例えば二戦みたいなの使って一旦書き出してみてください
するとやることが見えるようになると意外にできるもんです
では最後になりますが
私はこんなこともできないんだって
政党をバカにしていましたところがテニスの機能分析というやり方に出会い気がついて
しまったんです
生徒には能力がないのではなく実はやり方が間違っていただけだっていうこと
私は気合と根性を持って短所を改善することのみが始動だと親切なんだと勘違いしてい
ました
ところが長所を活用しながらできることを増やしていくと生徒って実は笑顔になるん
です
制度は才能がないのではなく不幸の連鎖にはまっていただけなんです
ただそれだけだったのに自分は勉強ができないからもうダメですって悲しいことを言わ
せていたのは指導者である私の責任なんです
不幸の連鎖を断ち切れなかった原因というのは
私にあるんです
だから今伝えたいんです
能力がないのではなくやり方が間違っていただけだということ
得意なやり方で得意な処理をして正しく伸ばしていけば誰もが笑顔になれます
そして
できることが増えていくと実は苦手なことにもチャレンジしてもしかしたらできるか
持ってチャレンジをしていくようになってきます
不幸の連鎖を断ち切るたった一つの方法
それはやり方を変えることです
自分の過去の経験からできないって決め付けてあきらめていませんか
諦めるその前に自分で自分を否定するその前に
今のやり方ではうまくいかないことが分かった
だったら別のやり方でやってみようって
体の機能に基づき
できることを増やし
たくさんの笑顔一緒につくっていきませんか
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]